foreign  [Music]  I would seems we're neighbors I've  acquired the Stratford Ranch  well this is the Yellowstone  and you have no rights here  Jacob you can't start a range War range  Wars already started  how much land do you want  I want the whole valley  either we take this fight to them or  it's coming us  men kill quick with a bullet or a noose  with their fight is with me  and I kill much slower  this is absolutely Wild  you're a hunter you're famous  tell the world what happens when they  cross me  greed will be the thing that kills us  off  did you turn the Rainwater  come with me  you know God Jacob doesn't  attack my family it's gonna be the last  thing you ever do